happy tuesday
we are back after a long weekend july
4th hopefully the fireworks didn't freak
out your pets
or give joe biden flashbacks to the war
of 1812.
in either case there's a lot of carpets
that need cleaning today
oh my god weird
it is weird though how even that holiday
is considered divisive these days and
not even by brits whose limey ass we
kicked right
i wasn't even born
i wasn't even born i take credit for it
but it's americans who don't like it
it's like only one half of the country
gets to enjoy july 4th while the other
half must trash it which is fine i mean
if you want to make july 4th a right
wing holiday we'll take it
you can have jane fonda's birthday
by the way happy 109th
she was great in the joker
but it's not really the case that people
hate july 4th it's just the people with
the pedestals who want you to feel
ashamed of this country so if you're a
fan of america for just one day somehow
that's a dog whistle like you're
celebrating the birthday of hitler and
not the cool one steve
i thought it was funny steve the guy
dates
steve hitler
just didn't think of changing his name
i mean they're already mad that you're
having fun you throw in family time the
old red white and blue plus grilled
meats it's more americana than limousine
leftists can bear all that's missing is
a t-shirt cannon filled with apple pie
that you can shoot right into my face
and so here they come barbra streisand
jessica justine bette midler carrie
washington ron perlman rob reiner they
all weighed in
and with michael moore that's literal
[Laughter]
wow he said that until rowe is
reinstated and congress is 51 female at
any party or dinner that he's invited to
he will only talk about abortion
which is funny
the assumption that he's invited to
parties
that's like me saying until roe is
reinstated i will not be sleeping with
chimpanzees
i know it's the opposite
until row is reinstated i will not
not be sleeping with chimpanzees
a little bestiality humor doesn't go
over well with this crew
it's the usual tribe though their
opinions are more meaningless than the
instructions on a pop-tart box
reiner who gets his cardio from
hyperventilating on twitter
called july 4th a strange thing to be
celebrating although not as strange as
him celebrating a successful movie
something he hasn't done in decades
meanwhile that dying ember of wokeness
espn featured an article called baseball
barbecue and losing freedom this fourth
of july well that'll ring a bell with
joe six-pack at home watching the game
espn is now like watching msnbc with a
few baseball scores thrown in it's the
only network that expects you to kneel
for the anthem before every game
then there's npr which skipped its
traditional reading of the declaration
of independence in favor of criticizing
it but nbr abandoning the reading of the
declaration is like caitlyn jenner
abandoning her men's suits
of course they did
finally our dear inspirational president
weighed in i wonder if liberty is under
assault both here and abroad
liberty is under salt
assault both here and abroad in recent
days
there's been reason to think that this
country is moving backward
that freedom is being reduced
that rights
we assume were protected are no longer
well you know that is a problem
i wonder who could be the president
oh i don't have to it's you you old coot
it's pretty funny they were talking
about july 4th just one day
it's not like a whole month called pride
i get it 30 days for rupaul in one day
for ben franklin
rupaul does have better legs though
but that's not the problem according to
a gallup poll the number of people who
say they're extremely proud of the
country is dwindling like joe biden's
neurologist we're seeing a decline
and why shouldn't there be when you have
a media academia and entertainment
repeating the idea that you are evil
it's like they're an abusive parent
telling his or her kid that he or she is
worthless guess what it might rub off so
now it's not just religion being
sidelined but patriotism too and the
agnostics and the bashers they're not
coming from some other country they're
born here they aren't immigrants they're
home grown
why is that well the people coming here
they get it they know what they're
leaving but the brats living here they
have no context there's no comparison
and now we mock the influences that
would help them search for life's
meaning so they just turned into empty
vessels we've removed god family
patriotism tradition the very same words
that make up pete hexith's [ __ ] stamp
[Laughter]
poor pete yes but and what do you
replace that with
subservience without redemption
now i don't own a bible or a flag
legally i'm not even allowed to own
scissors
but i understand the importance of both
and you see it when both go missing when
they're gone holy crap the alternative
is pretty scary the goal of the woke
left is to replace religion with an
ideology that demands the same obedience
but without the forgiveness of a
religion it's insane at least with
religion you get heaven but with wokism
you get hell on earth
and now it's being done to patriotism
because a love for your country is a
shared experience among people of
different pigments which runs counter to
identity politics identity politics only
believes in empathy among people who
share fixed traits so you and i cannot
see eye to eye if my eyes are blue and
yours aren't according to the laws of
intersectional wokism the only human who
gets you has to be exactly like you
therapy is so important have to share
this trauma with someone who truly
understands it's why i can only share
these feelings with another anarchist
polyamorous they
so thank you doctor
i couldn't agree more debra
my last therapist
drove a car that uses gasoline and she
was happily married with two kids i mean
how could someone like that ever help me
she would never get it but i do deb
that'll be 500 a little short can i pay
in a couple weeks
so
it's the magic of television
so it's no wonder patriotism which
unites us over values and not race is a
threat to the left hence this two-step
process replace what unifies us with
what divides us and erase redemption
with historical guilt made as a
permanent stain so could the death of
patriotism follow the death of religion
much like the death of a heavy drinker
follows the death of his liver
maybe but july 4th is now kind of like a
religious holiday purely optional it's
not a patriotic birthday it's now just a
reminder of the original sin of
oppression the sins of the father are
now your own there's nothing you can do
there's no confession no forgiveness
there's only apology after apology to
the mob who sees them as appetizers and
you are the meal
tonight's guest
she passed the bar and then went back to
order two for what margaritas
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
this dyslexic comedian will make you llo
comedian jeff dye
and you may remember her from such tv
shows as cops and live pd
foxy's contributor cat tim
[Applause]
and a folding chair is his money clip my
massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion
tyra
so emily it was our country's birthday
yesterday i trust you behaved yourself
but had a patriotic good time i did i
celebrated yes yes is that what one does
on a birthday you don't go to the
birthday boy or birthday girl and dress
them down for their for their history do
you no birthdays are for popping out of
cakes
i'd like to see that
not you i mean that i mean i'd like to
see benji i'd like to see benjamin
franklin pop out
not her i'll watch it
i'm talking about it
yeah but i work here
for god's sake pesky rules
um so look i'll weigh in on on hollywood
celebrities weighing in with all of
those tweets right and katy perry sent
out one where she said that women have
less rights here in this country than a
firework and citing her top 10 song or
her number one song fireworks um and
the insularity of these celebrities is
so asinine to me it's so nauseating
because these comments are totally
delusional right so she's talking about
like what voting rights yeah that we
have less voting rights here what about
in kenya where pregnant women can't
leave the house so they absolutely have
no constructive right to vote or an oman
where women have to vote as their
husbands do or yeah oh sorry sorry
or a risk of death jeff oh my god
okay
and then when we talk about you know
school girls which i think are sort of
the majority of her audience they are
the reason she is wealthy and in
afghanistan under the taliban they can
even go to school past sixth grade so
for her to be so tone deaf for her to
not realize this is the greatest country
that here it's amazing to live in um to
me just
is one more indicator how insulated
hollywood is how
out of touch their opinions are and if
she needs to learn she should just ask
her husband or her baby daddy who's from
the uk where abortion rights for example
are even more restrictive than she
married to oh orlando orlando bloom
that's correct that's correct exactly
excellent well i'm glad we got that in
there you know jeff how did you spend
your fourth were you angry defiant
uh did you sleep right through it no
it's actually i didn't hear anything
about bette midler and all these
celebrities saying that we shouldn't
celebrate i was too busy actually
celebrating the holiday yeah uh yeah
because
that's what you do and it's nice and i
love the holiday and i think it's great
i think it's a very confusing turns out
you don't have to listen to bette miller
she's not in charge of your freedoms
yes i didn't even notice that she said
anyways she's an idiot that is true and
she uh she definitely didn't speak to my
heart
that's for sure right you know uh kat um
i did bring up these like it's kind of
like they're replacing certain things
that maybe we didn't really i don't know
appreciate like i didn't really think
about what patriotism is or even what
religion is until you suddenly see what
the left wants to replace it with what
do you make of that hypothesis i don't
think that most people do think about it
even now
like i just all these tweets are like
well now i'm not celebrating the country
on the fourth of july like how much were
you thinking about the country before
right you know like you don't have to be
all excited about the reason for the
party to want to go to a party if it's
going to be fun
yes
i also didn't see any of this stuff
because i was celebrating
and it's just they also think that
they're just so noble and so cool for
you know all this stuff you know
tweeting all this stuff and i'm just
gonna also say like i'm not that
impressed by it it also didn't piss me
off if you want to be miserable then go
ahead yeah that's true also katy perry
thinks babies are fireworks
[Laughter]
i have to hear that yeah one more time
like i'm going to blow my head off yes
babies are human things not fireworks
yes
they'd be fun though if they were hard
firework
a little bit on the top of their head
yeah you're not allowed to have children
what if we fused a firework onto babies
everything you're saying is a bad idea
hear me out no i'm gonna stop roman
candle oh my god no all right no just
not you can't even be your uncle how did
you spend your fourth of july tyrone oh
man i was uh
me and the brothers got together we
thought about a revolution
[Laughter]
oh it was all the red tape and it was
all the work so we said screw it we
barbecued
let up some fireworks and watch some
baseball so here's the thing you want to
fix it with the celebrities all you have
to do to all of them is book them
give them a show on the fourth of july
and they'll love it again
that's it that's all it is because
every one of them
they weren't booked so
the hell was the fourth of july because
i'm pretty sure i had to sit through
nine hours of katy perry's fireworks on
the fourth of july everywhere over and
over and here's the deal it this is
what's beautiful in america you don't
have to celebrate it and no one's gonna
come after you but what's hilarious is
espn the writer the brother who wrote
this was trashing america and he was
talking about how unpatriotic it used to
be he forgot that day game that he went
to in new york for the yankees red sox
game the reason why it's a day game is
so we can have fireworks at night to
celebrate the fourth of july he forgot
that and he also forgot it's a very
forgiving country that you can be
accused of choking your wife in public
and plead down which means you did it
and still have your job and still be
able to give an opinion
nowhere else but in america can you do
that he seemed to forget all those
things when he was talking so real easy
give them all jobs on 4th of july no
one's watching anyway because we're
going to play outside so they can have
put them all on the show together how
smart is what's her face katy perry to
name a song fireworks knowing that it
will be played at least one day a year
right
yeah i was so by former band
or mean yeah or she lost the rights to
the to the record company and it's at
amusement parks and stuff now so that's
why she's mad i'm going to release a
record in which all of my songs are
going to be based on holidays
right easter bunny something called like
the eggs
christmas again it will be my next album
is going to be called pride month so i
get
more every year
more
six months ride month
later a year
that's great
should be two months i'm gonna push for
two months next year damn it up next he
called out grocers and angered the
wokester
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else